this is a Ford Model T from 1911 and
under the hood it's hiding a secret see
this car is actually an electric vehicle
it was recently converted from gas to
electric by this map 80 year old former
electrical engineer Robert Knight and
it's not just rubber or antique Fords as
EV adoption increases around the globe a
string of startups have emerged with the
aim of retrofitting and upcycling gas
cars into electric ones
foreign
okay so firstly what does it take to
convert a car well as Robert found out
it's both simple and really hard so the
initial conversion was here but since
then I've been modifying you to
modifying it and I've had mistake after
mistake step one is to drain the fuel
tank and completely remove the engine
block that can create a space where
batteries and an electric motor can be
installed next is the task of hooking
that motor up to the drivetrain and
wiring in a battery management system
after that it's just a case of hooking
up the new drivetrain to the controls or
in Robert's case installing these
various switches Ford purists Look Away
Now third one is your advertise come
into the bed wrecking wrecking a 1911
Ford Model 3. Robert tells me he's
managed to get around 25 miles of range
out of his conversion which is just
enough to get him to the local shops and
back and the conversion cost under two
thousand dollars most of which came from
the sale of the engine so it's trivia
absolute trivia
so if it's possible to do a relatively
cheap conversion yourself is it possible
to make money from doing it to find out
I've come to UK based EV upcycling
startup Lunas each of these cars may
look like an original classic car but
they've actually all been completely
stripped and rebuilt from the ground up
with a brand new electric Powertrain
that's the only bit of that car I can
afford to touch that's because the
starting price for the conversion of
these Classics is around 370
000 and up which is around the same
price as buying a competition condition
classic but it's not just classic cars
that Lunas is upcycling they're also
taking commercial fleet vehicles like
these garbage trucks and running them
through a similar upcycling process
here's CEO David Lorenz some of the
trucks behind me today these are
seven-year-old Vehicles they had done a
hundred thousand miles over their seven
year life they were tried and tested by
the OEM for a million miles
fundamentally it is so logical to
upcycle the vehicle that already exists
to clean their powertrain David told me
that for Luna's upcycling actually
presents a faster route to Market and
means that their trucks can be thousands
of dollars cheaper than buying a new EV
equivalent we do 80 less work all of the
bumpers windscreen wipers mechanism we
don't have to face these challenges
these vehicles have been so well
engineered in the first place the main
reason David founded
more carbon dioxide from the loop than
if you buy new EVS if you go and replace
5000 vehicles with clean air powertrain
Vehicles that's fantastic in one sense
but what happens to your old 5000
Vehicles they're going to end up on
cargo ships they're going to end up in
less privileged countries and they're
going to sweat longer hours than you are
using them for naturally producing more
emissions so if retrofitting and
upcycling could potentially present a
faster path towards hitting climate
targets and there are businesses out
there making money from it why aren't
more oems doing it well companies like
Ford and GM have made some tentative
steps into retrofitting by offering
electric versions of certain components
but according to Patrick hertzk
Automotive analysts and partner at
McKinsey automakers have bigger fish to
fry they have their hands for scaling up
standard EV production getting
gigafactory supply of batteries within
their supply chain trying to drive costs
down another reason is that releasing
retrofitting options could potentially
sabotage sales of new cars as some
customers may choose to retrofit instead
of replace but possibly the biggest
reason reason is that it can be very
hard to turn a profit from retrofitting
everyday Vehicles after all while these
classic cars and garbage trucks may look
very different they're both expensive
enough to make retrofitting worth it the
classic cars retain value and there's
economies of scale in retrofitting a
small Fleet of identical vehicles or as
David said there is no vehicle that
can't be upcycled to clean air
powertrain it's just is it a
cost-effective solution what is the cost
to this but there may be something that
could help shift the balance and make
retrofitting more popular subsidies the
extent that these retrofitters can fully
access additional subsidy schemes or
regulatory encouragement can certainly
ever have an impact and if you want to
know that might look like it's already
happening in friends their retrofitted
electric vehicles are eligible for a few
thousand dollars in government subsidies
and you have companies like Renault
teaming up with retrofitter are fit to
offer conversions of Cheaper classic
vehicles and startups like transition
one offering conversions on like City
cars but here's the thing even with
subsidies it can be really hard to turn
a profit while I was reporting this
story transition one stopped trading as
the company said it no longer had the
financial means to continue so without
significant government incentives it's
unlikely you'll see oems getting into
the retrofitting game anytime soon but
keep an eye on those retrofitting
startups because they could have a lot
of vehicles to work with while EVS may
have made up 10 of all new car sales
last year there's still a fraction of
the estimated 1.4 billion vehicles on
the planet
foreign